[Music]
[Music]
morning morning morning morning morning
morning morning it is Thursday June 25th
and this is tea with Gary Vee big shout
out to everybody in the comments
good morning Tammy J Jorge Mike Swagger
what's good Terrell hope in the building
Lucia Lisette what's good Terrell hope
great to see you KJ Sriman in the
building big shout out to twitch and to
Facebook and to periscope and to
LinkedIn and to Instagram everybody
great to see you 24/7 fishings in the
building before we start go right up to
the URL go right up to the URL right now
and share it share it on Twitter sharing
on Facebook please take a screenshot and
putting your Instagram stories let's get
people on the dirty T with T with Gary
Vee and I'm excited about this episode
as you can tell by the energy so let's
get right into it good morning good
morning good morning good morning good
morning Tom Brown what's good it was
good how you feeling I'm feeling great
how are you and I'm doing excellent I
can't complain
where you at Ellie thanks for getting up
early yeah a hundred percent not usually
I've just I'm usually going to sleep
this time well it's great to see man
what can I answer for him too I was
going to ask you like with the success
of all the apps like tick-tock and
everything else where do you see the
music industry going in the future like
not just being the traditional record
label but do you think it's possible
that like tick tock or any of these apps
can be a future record label I think I
think they could I don't think they will
I think tick tock s'more MTV 1985 it's
kind of what all the kids are and then
thus whatever music's pop and it pops I
think you've seen what Spotify and
really SoundCloud more than anything has
done which is you don't need a record
label to get
Bossier right I think the the leverage
that the internet gives to the artist
versus the distribution it's always a
content and distribution game and and
the record labels had all the leverage
for so long because you couldn't get
your music to the world unless you were
signed had a CD or a record put in a Sam
Goody or a virgin store right and then
you gotta get promoted on TRL like that
was the Machine now me and you can go
into the studio at 4 a.m. back to your
point earlier usually up it's something
I got real [ __ ] cloud out here put it
on my thing link it to SoundCloud it
gets going you start making mean culture
you look at you know what went up with
old country road like it's the game is
completely flipped look good they sure
they could more likely Noach platforms
or we you should want to stay neutral
and have everybody come into them
because that's even more business that's
the distribution and as soon as they
start a label they alienate other people
that are out there and so tick tock
doesn't want to lose rihanna because
they start a label and came up with Shmi
jana
and a computer sound right so I think
it's more about using those platforms
and understanding that if I'm an artist
I build as big as I can have all the
leverage and then of and I think record
labels are gonna have to evolve into
things like they're gonna have to show
value they can't just do distribution so
I think record labels are gonna have to
be able to build you you know a lot of
the way I think about the Vayner machine
like when I deployed against my wine
business and how I think about music and
film and everything is eventually the
only thing that's gonna matter is if
somebody can actually get you more
awareness because everything else is a
commodity yeah 100% cuz this is crazy to
see the bump and there's producers and
artists that I know that now have real
records that never would get a deal
before and not 35 years old with a song
that's number one on tick tock this is
all I've been yelling about for [ __ ]
15 years and I and obviously when tick
tock you know and musically and then
became tick tock like I've been
screaming about this and nobody believes
it so if you believe it
definitely not people that are little
further
you know the people who have no choice
believe it they're like yeah but
nobody's to your point nobody's ass I
mean nobody gives a [ __ ] I'm 35 you know
what I mean yeah the people I worry
about are the ones that got a little
something going have signed a deal are
in the game cuz they they don't realize
that they kind of look at it as like
[ __ ] I've been grinding out here for 15
years you know to just get to this spot
right you know percent and I'm like no
no no don't do that go all in on that I
look at Jason Dooley oh yeah he's good
friend of mine he's like smash and it's
insane and it makes me so happy for him
because he's like almost like the DJ
Khaled of this right Khaled had a real
career yes snapchat changed his life her
new position Jason had a real career but
let's not get it twisted his relevant
score has gone through the [ __ ] roof
who's 17 year olds that knew Jason was
like that and look in six months they
love the man 25 million followers is
insane and now he can like take a step
back and really put out a track a record
a [ __ ] drop something and it's gonna
work he and a year ago if he dropped
that it wasn't gonna work that's just
real life Jason saying how it changed
the game anything and it will continue
to happen today it's tick tock tomorrow
something called like sling read is
gonna come out and it's like this is
just a culture of youth culture will
always be like this he it's kind of
always be like this
yeah I think record label is there
forever change now and and and they have
to now bring value in a different way
and it's in keep pushing Tommy I really
appreciate man everybody followed this
man you have a pretty good thank you
thank you yeah listen and the game's
changing in everything real estate like
when I think about the power of like
being a great communicator and having a
machine behind it if I want to start a
vein or reality if I want to sell manor
records if I want to start Vader films
all of those things are gonna do better
because I've been focused on the thing
that actually matters which is getting
[ __ ] people to see it not get it out
into the world I can put a movie on the
[ __ ] internet and put a passcode you
know kind of like and be in the game I
don't need [ __ ] theaters and let me
rephrase that today you need theater
still
kind of like I saw the music thing ten
years ago now you really don't need it
but SoundCloud and tik-tok things that
they share you don't need a label the
way they needed it now labels have to
evolve and bring more value
same with theatres you still kind of
need it we don't have that smash movie
hit that we all went to the website and
just all watched and they tokenized and
they let people share codes and like
they got their money but it's coming
don't get it twisted
it's [ __ ] coming let's keep it moving
let's [ __ ] go you're not joking with
the goat my god Jerry Rice what is good
man to legend it is a pleasure to see
you my friend wow I'm fired up they got
you how are you I'm doing great man I'm
sure you know it's crazy
a lot of people love throwing around
goats but my man you know it's funny in
that same draft class my favorite New
York jet of all time altoon ah and and
my whole life my whole life I would
always like when I was a kid kid I would
always try to debate that altoon was up
to your class but my man you really
goaded it out and I'm it's a real
pleasure I mean honestly it was really
easy to get on my AFC fan so it was easy
when you were killing in San Francisco
when you came to the Raiders and did
work and we had some big games like I
was definitely salty but now I'm feeling
better now that now that you're retired
and doing all that stuff so it's great
to see you how are you I know my man
trust me I know that and I know in a
very short period of time we took keto
Brian and altoon before Dan Marino and
Jerry Rice I know exactly my dress
listen it's a real pleasure to have you
here what's on your mind hey look man I
just you know I've started a new company
called go field we have four drinks now
it's a healthier drink and my thing over
the years I played the game over 20
years it was all about what I put in my
body and that gave me the opportunity
where I going to feel in excel so that's
what I'm trying to do with my new energy
drink and it's gonna be more ecommerce
right now because of everything that's
going on with the pad
and I'm sorry to interrupt but I don't
know if you heard the last thing but
what's funny is in the same way that
record labels are different same thing
with retailers going direct to consumer
is exactly what you should do build it
up and then have Walmart and Albertsons
and Publix and Costco begging you for it
instead of you begging them you're gonna
get every meeting cuz of you I'm sure
the buyers at all these big shops are
all gonna take the Jerry Rice meeting
but but what I'd rather you have more
than the legendary status as leverage is
actual sales to consumers that's gonna
carry even more well I think I get I
think Gary's internet is a cutout of
course it always has to go outside far
away from the router I'll text them
definitely not you oh it's his computer
crashed she said great here's a fun fact
I don't know anything about sports but
you were the first athlete that I ever
even heard of because my cousin had your
San Francisco 49ers Jersey on and I
think yeah that's the only that's all I
know
like I didn't even know any other
athletes and I just saw him where it
said rice on the back and I was like
who's that so then I looked it up
somehow and I was like it was Jerry Rice
over the years you know playing for 20
years playing with probably the greatest
quarterback you know with Montana the
greatest coach you know Bill Walsh
and the greatest owner so we we had a
great ride
what do you miss the most you know I
think what I miss the most is the
camaraderie going into a hospital
environment back taken back to you know
try that out I'm back Michael listen
this computer's Dustin we have to talk
to team my computer's been crashing just
randomly so I mean that's fine when it's
you know meetings here and there but not
when we're live with the legend anyway
Jerry I totally get it so keep going
book what can I answer for you well
what's on your mind because we just
wanted to make it convenient for the
consumer and you know and also where
they don't pay that big overhead price
and all of that so you know I think
we're moving in the right direction is
it available for everybody right now if
they wanted to try it their website you
can go to WWE and you can order we also
got a prayer coming out so I'm excited
about the whole thing because you know
me hey Gary good thing about me I do not
put my name on just anything you know I
have to really believe in it and the
thing is I have you know pretty much
assemble a great team it's all about
teamwork
you know I didn't I didn't catch 1549
you know balls you know 200 touchdowns
22800 95 yards rapid teamwork man listen
I said listen let me throw something at
you that I think is gonna really work
for you I think that you should and by
the way let's get connected after this
and we can get on a call with you and
your team I think that you should create
an access pack if everyone went to go
field and saw that if they bought ten
cases that they would get into a small
group that gets an hour with Jerry on
like this in a group to ask QA I think
you can get I think you see where I'm
gone man yes access to you is so
valuable you can go live like this
digitally and have 500 people in there
they all bought ten cases 25 cases a
case of month
I think if you layer access because of
who you are I mean there's a ton of
people watching right now who weren't
gonna buy the energy drink even though
they love you but the fact to be in part
of a small group getting a Q&A with you
access to you now they buy the 10 cases
a lot of them will then you know because
it's a lot for them will give out the
product to their friends which will
create word-of-mouth so I think there's
a real leverage of access yeah and
that's why I want you on my team man ok
circle I live my life wishing that you
were on my team let's go listen let's
get connected after this we'll have a
real call get your team together let's
get my admins together will will will
get a real meeting down okay your go
pewter gray tank long time and we don't
send you a case of go whew okay I love
it let's put the URL here for everybody
you have it because I wanna make sure
everybody knows it did you catch that
Dustin or do you need the URL what what
is the euro go field how do you spell
cherry I just wanna make sure he's
catching if you go ATL uel calm go W
feel calm and just you know go feel I
love it Gerry right this was such a fun
surprise I appreciate you my man you
it's a real honor you got me let's go
let's go
take care all right we'll talk soon
thank you thank you that was amazing
that fired me up that man is you know if
you're 44 like me like you don't even
understand what that guy did like just
he said sheer separation from him being
the best receiver in football to the
second best was enormous go fuel in the
building there there it is anyway let's
keep this moving Wow what's going on
what's up Simon how are you
I'm fantastic how are you I'm quite well
I'm quite well you're just like you
always wear that red hat every time I
see you I in content I see that I used
to have a red hair and I had to shake
that off about like a month ago because
of like a stupid YouTube challenge and I
was bald like a month ago now I have a
little bit of my hair back but I'm not
sure if I want to dye it back to red
because I don't know I kind of feel like
not having red hair but then I'm like
it's branding I listen to you a lot
branding is important so I think a red
hat is pretty cool but man like what is
this world you were just on the phone
with like it's so crazy I don't know
it's just really crazy but um
yeah I have a couple I have a couple
question please please so you say like
you say all the time that it's really
important to you know block out any of
the of the noise really like to not
listen to people giving you credits not
to listen to people who hate you and all
that which is all right or or as we
continue to mature through the process
taking it with a grain of salt you know
one of the things I worry about when I
say things like don't listen to anybody
is then people become audacious and are
tone deaf so it's what I what I mean by
that is like look don't get too high
don't get too low when you hear
information have the humility to admit
you're wrong have have the you know feel
nice you know I almost don't want people
you know when Jerry Rice says to you
you're the [ __ ] goat you know I
I need to take a hundredth of a second
to feel nice about that Semien
especially the 12 year old me but the
truth is when he just said that I you
know it's a hundredth of a second of
like that's so cool than it but then you
just kind of move on and you remind
yourself yeah but you know I've
shortcomings you know I'm just a man and
then and the second better data that
allows you to also when somebody says
you're a snake oil salesman or you're a
piece of [ __ ] you can be it you can be
compassionate to why they say that they
may not like the bravado of red hair but
they don't really know you
so yeah yes I do say tune out but that
doesn't mean be tone-deaf and that's a
little clarity on that okay yeah that
actually I think that answers it pretty
well because I was like isn't it like
a resource that you can use to you know
like it pumps you the [ __ ] up and you're
like oh man I'm gonna go and then the
next constant piece I'm gonna create is
gonna be like it has a different energy
no less so it's like a resource yes it's
like a it's like a it's like ice cream
you know everything in moderation like
yeah you know when people like you can't
have that that gets a little crazy it's
kind of like soy parents are with
alcohol you look in the countries where
alcohol is you know is demonized and it
pushed very as like a negative you see a
lot of kids when they get to 18 and 21
or whatever it may be really struggle
with their relationship with alcohol if
you look at cultures where alcohol is
not demonized
those kids have a much better
relationship with alcohol through their
whole life and so I think one of the
things that I don't want to do is I
don't want to let other people's
opinions have too much too much weight
whether it's yellow or cod because then
you'll have a better relationship with
it yeah and the better relationship with
yourself I think I think like the one
thing where I notice where I need to
make my cut is like my self-worth needs
to be independent of everything like
it's not like the worst thing is when
you define yourself over a numbers or
hat for any sort correct like
achievement because it's all just work
basically and like you just said the
human itself needs to stay you know
clean like you're just a human you're
not gonna be any more than human you're
never gonna be like a superhuman or
something but you're also not a piece of
[ __ ] when your numbers go down and you
know why yeah that is why the person
have just said Russia has a massive
drinking problem there's an overlay on
that which is just general depression of
the ecosystem they live in anyway
nonetheless what's important about that
is some is that if you're really
passionate about the process yeah all of
a sudden the results don't carry the
weight the fact that you're doing it
carries the weight yeah and and there
there's like that place of authenticity
it's so important that you just need to
do what you like really like you you
need to be hard honest to yourself I
feel like and if you start doing [ __ ] to
you know get results and it's always
gonna kind of it's always gonna fetch it
it's always always gonna fail which
y-you know it's which is all these
different themes no different than that
proper gentleman who said you're wrong
Gary Russia has a problem he's right
about that but then I overlaid but
there's another variable same to this
talk which is all these variables you
know about loving the process versus the
results let's you not worry about
numbers or accolades cheering or booing
and then and then if you layer another
thing on top of it
what this is why I'm spending almost all
my time of how in the world are we gonna
make happiness the win not fame and
money like actually how are we gonna
make that happen and where the struggle
for me is I am most happy when I'm
buying and selling like garage saleing
sports cards I'm my most happy as a
businessman and I happen to be a good
businessman so I'm not gonna be in a
place where I'm going to not not have
money so my voice on happiness over
money is gonna be blurry because the one
thing that made me happy was actually
something that made money but if I had a
little time about the process being and
buying and selling right yeah yes that's
what I don't know if you've ever seen my
garage sale videos it's why it's why I'm
so happy in those elements like waking
up at 6:00 a.m. to go buy something for
me I mean I was up at 2 o'clock in the
morning the other night buying five
hundred Tim Hardaway rookie cards for 80
cents apiece
with the hope that it's gonna be worth
three dollars in a year cuz basketball
cards are going up and it made me so
happy I was up at two o'clock in the
morning doing it cool so I'm a merchant
imma you know I'm a church Kageyama you
know I would have been a traitor if I
was 500 years ago I would have been the
person that went in the woods found a
rock and was beautiful convinced the
person that was that had sheep that it
was a beautiful Rock I got the Sheep
feed my family it's that's my denied but
musicians artists parents teachers we
need more people to talk about loving
what they do like we need a medicine we
need a famous famous social media
teacher who's so [ __ ] happy who she or
he makes fifty-three thousand a year and
inspires an entire generation to say oh
that's it that happiness in the eye not
the 53k because oh by the way
fifty-three
kay knows how to manage their money
lives in a very lovely home you know
pays their mortgage you know saves up
for a Disney trip you're like there's so
much happiness out there that is not
being heralded and what we Harold is
business success
you know fame success which is it fine
and understandable but if we just
balance that with heralding people that
are happy not tearing down everybody not
canceled culture but but positivity of
people that are happy yeah if you're
watching right now and you're genuinely
happy please make a video of like I'm
happy I make sixty three thousand a year
being a clerk I make a hundred four
thousand like let's let's tell the world
how many people are happy that aren't
millionaires and then [ __ ] will get very
interesting yeah absolutely that's
that's a really good point I think like
the way the main problem lays was like
we just stated is that people see
definition in success that is metric
metric able and stuff and measurable but
I think you need to get to the we need
to get to the core of like why people
are in the base so unhappy and and you
can have that base thought of like I'm
not good so I need to define myself over
something like numbers or something like
that that's such a great point like I
think I think this gets into self-esteem
and insecurity this is why parenting
became a Content pillar for me like yeah
it's huge everything is like the biggest
thing I feel like just like that in the
last month's I I've done so much like
working out of like trauma and [ __ ] that
is based on like childhood stuff and I
feel like that's basically everything
like all the reason for all the you know
pressure that I put on myself in the
last years of my career and I've been in
that place where I find myself over
numbers and stuff I was a compress when
it went down
why yeah why are these artists doing if
it started after me you know again if
you lick if you look at the two prior
comments that were below one gentleman
was for a person or woman I couldn't
tell by the name is unhappy making 26 K
the next gentleman the one who made the
point about Russia MMA he's thrilled at
30 K right Natasha is talking about
fixing the sink you know here's Malcolm
he's thrilled at under 50 K that's a big
man
come - can do a lot more for the world
in a lot of ways then I can at this
point my life if I was making content
when I was 23 24 25 making you know 32k
40k I would have crush because there's
so much more there yeah like like we
need to we need to attack this yeah and
I think it's awesome but wait that
doesn't mean there isn't issues with
like separation of wealth there's things
we have to change but we have but we
have to also we also have to while we're
tearing down things that aren't working
we desperately have to build up things
that are working and Malcolm [ __ ] -
is working like literally that's a big
[ __ ] deal
Malcolm please make content why you're
happy please anyway son I appreciate you
bro you're on your way like where your
mindset is right now is exactly right
Thank You Man like that honestly I
cannot like I cannot really put in words
how much of an impact like all you all
you and you all of your content have
like the last two or three years I don't
know like it started resonating with me
more and more and in like by now I'm
like at the point where I'm like every
single video that I see I'm like yeah
like obviously like that's the only the
only way that's logic the only way
that's that makes sense and stuff
anymore
and yeah and I feel like and I feel it's
still so like so much the opposite of
what everyone else in the world
basically thinks is right so I feel like
man we need to wait the people have so
yeah hold on you man well I will take
care thank you all right hey look at
this rock we're rich it's true branded
like like I I'm actually genuinely
curious if I crack and just become a
garage sailor and baseball card dealer I
don't think it's impossible I think you
know I enjoy too many other things I'm
doing but I don't know man
anyway let's keep it going
thank you so much for having us dude I
think I want to start off by just saying
you know thank you from the bottom of
our hearts for for doing what you do
right in a world where we are constantly
being told how to act or you know how to
be a certain way you're preaching not
the opposite right there's strength in
who we are and
use that to our part oh thank you so
much man that's a big time of like whoo
Momo Shak is and why we do certain
things oh where is Momo Shaq
so we're based out of Dallas Texas I
love it
all so a big shout out to Zane man we go
way way way back 2015 I don't know if
you know this but he was the freshman
orientation lead when I was first
getting into college so yeah man he's
like he's the huge supporter so love
that guy
it's awesome what can I change sure so
before we get to the question real quick
just want to provide a bit of context
right so in this call right now we're
representing three different countries
so I'm from Nepal my name is Leeson this
is my mom chef me new head chef yeah
we're both from Nepal and then I'm
banging up on Vietnam and I'm Daniel
yeah we rep that immigrant life like
hard right like we really vibe with it
and I think growing up here the biggest
thing for us was the focus was you know
going through that societal path of you
know go to college get a good job so
that was our focus right so we went to
college that's where our stories connect
as well I met these guys and then I
happen to graduate they just the
semester earlier than them my chef crowd
actually right yeah that's big and then
got the corporate job right made it to
corporate and you know as I was going
through the daily motions of learning
and things like that I think some
something in me clicked and I was like
oh I thought I made it but I don't quite
feel it yet right so I would relay the
same message to these guys and we would
like huddle up brainstorm come up with
ideas fast forward to December December
2017 you know we found your content and
then we just decide to execute by no
means do we know what we're doing or did
we know what we're doing know what we're
doing at that time nobody exactly knows
the only the only reason I'm further
along in some ways is because I started
doing it at 6:00 the only reason you
know at 44 I can have this kind of
entrepreneurial juice is I was unlike
you know you delivered for your mom I
kind of didn't I did but I didn't for
school because I went completely which
is crazy in hindsight but I was I've
been a businessman now for 38 years for
real
like it's all I've ever thought about
and so I've so many reps but at six
seven eight nine ten I mean I was making
mistakes when I was 17 I was making I
mean mistake last week me and AJ we're
talking yesterday about major mistakes
were both making right now nobody knows
what they're doing in the beginning
that's the best part of doing instead of
learning teaching and watch watching me
or going to business school is great but
it's zero compared to living it Zink
absolutely experience is the best
teacher not we feel that so yeah 2017 we
started off as a pop-up branch of going
direct to consumers that like you were
talking about with Jerry earlier and
then with Kovac naturally happening
right we had to find a way to pivot so
now we're doing packaged Momo's so if
you check out our IG you'll see the
little bag and you know we're doing
pickup orders with customers or not yeah
no we're just because you order these
too much in the shipping process we're
gonna lose too much just cuz it's frozen
goods right I'm an idea I've been
sitting on this idea I'm gonna share
with you I think that you do you feel
like your recipe is a secret in any way
or no absolutely I'm trying to figure
out I'm trying to figure out how people
can send deconstruction boxes so like I
love this idea that I have good feeling
that thousands of people right now would
literally buy a deconstructing
deconstructed dumpling box from you that
then every Friday night from 6 to 9 p.m.
you know Eastern which would catch
everybody kind of you're doing live
cooking with Mama's chef with you 3
characters and people are actually
making dumplings along with you now the
fun part is you're like look this is
gonna be you these aren't official memos
because we have a little secret
mama show do the secret that you know
like let's not show her right now you
like move it away all right Mama's doing
the secret stuff right now we're back I
think there's a way for you to build a
brand that isn't directly selling what
you sell but all of a sudden I've just
taken you to a national brand instead of
a local brand and I think you could
actually sell a shitload of [ __ ] maker
packs I think it's a big idea and I
think for a lot of people out there that
don't have some secret to the in green
it's a huge idea thoughts no absolutely
I mean on the whiteboard here we
actually have that written down as one
of the next things that we wanted to
tackle which is like DIY mum move move
that what idea to the top of that
[ __ ] whiteboard for sure
thank you Mannie and then I think like
just go piggybacking off of that our
question was gonna be like knowing what
you know now right let's say you're the
CEO of MoMA Shack what are some like
tactical immediate things that you would
focus on and what are some you know
macro level vision things that you would
focus on in the next five to ten years
to make that a nationwide brand I would
decide if I want to do franchising or if
I want to own that's number one you have
to make that decision in your game
number and by the way there's no right
decision that's just you need to be
self-aware and figure out yourselves
number two I would create the
deconstructing dumblings pack and sell
it to everybody in the country
I really wanna miss I think local brands
can go national when they don't think
they can somebody makes ice cream ship
out ice cream makers and do videos with
people at night making ice cream it
won't be exactly your ice cream but your
brands gonna get huge if you you know if
your winery and you're small and you're
in Texas for example which is not an
emerging wine region create winemaking
kits that that's months of content
because that [ __ ] sits in the ground in
the in the garage excuse me I'm very hot
on that and then the other thing I would
do is immediately become a media company
you're a media company that happens to
sell dumplings and what do I mean by
that is when I see this foursome this is
incredible inspiration for not only
immigrants for not only brown people for
white people for you know for black
people for for all types and I think a
podcast or a documenting you know either
of LA you know and I know you know this
I say this all time watch what I do not
what I say the interview questions are
in my own behavior you know this is why
I want like to me the reason to watch me
at some point the concept of what I'm
talking that's gonna click whether
that's the first time you hear me or a
year or two later and you start off not
liking me but then it clicked it will
cuz it's it's way bigger than me
happen to messenge it um the the bigger
reason I think people should follow me
is they should do what I'm doing I think
you should do a coffee show every
morning with your small little group
named after same concept as tea with
Gary bee after three months of it all of
a sudden people come into you buy to buy
coffee in the mornings and dumplings at
night now you've become a restaurant
that has multiple times of the day
period you could become the number one
coffee player in your local area because
you did a coffee show and you talked
about testing the whole show is a
hundred days of you trying different
coffee beans that you bought and you're
doing Q&A and just talking about Dallas
culture immigrant culture the Mavericks
I don't give a [ __ ] right and then all
of a sudden people know you as the
coffee person even though they're your
emotion and all the so now you're
selling coffee and now PETA now then
local news wants to cover you because
like get this story a dumpling shop is
now beating out Starbucks in Dallas
let's talk you see where I'm going yeah
that's huge absolutely I got to figure
out how not to like pick favorites I
mean it's probably got to be New York
but I might want to do it in LA let me
give you some thought or maybe we'll do
both and then we'll do like a whole and
I'll make sure it's part of my weekly
blog to give you tons of exposure
because you're doing that nice thing I
want to return tenfold
so we'll lock it in you'll work with
same well get that there ducks you don't
bring mama you're not coming all right
let's keep rocking it yeah there's just
something about the energy of the show
hey
I've been documenting my starting or
about to talk with Gary Beyonce talks
though I love it Laura and hi baby E how
are you good
we added two silent yeast the end of his
name in your honor very safe oh we got
some swag on today actually this bunch
story this is the first piece of baby
clothing I ever bought and we actually
got it like two years before we even had
him and it happens didn't we talk so
cool what's it say it's the hustler one
I love it
you're very sweet I see it I see it I'm
so so honored
what can I answer for you yeah well
first I wanted to say a particular
specific thank you that I've really
notice I haven't heard someone call you
out on and that is you always give both
genders in your examples when you're
talking about the next CEO the next app
developer or whatever and for me I'm
similar to you a grip in the 80s and 90s
and every [ __ ] textbook had examples
of only men only white men and it's easy
to grow up thinking gosh I guess women
and people of color didn't do anything
so I really I noticed that from you and
I really appreciate it thank you for
saying that
so in preparing for this I've been
listening over and over to two specific
key segments that I kind of wanted to
see how you could maybe help me apply to
a bit of a variation that I want to take
now with my business because of some of
my Friday's have really changed now that
I'm a new mommy
so Tom Levine you talked with him he's a
good fiction writer so you gave him the
advice like a $5 a month subscription
access to helping people with fiction
writing and then Melissa from it fits
bars you had the idea of access
yeah access but you get like ironically
it's what I just told Jerry Rice to do
as well yeah exactly yeah totally so so
my background is I was a big nerd in
school I totally bought in unlike you I
bought into the whole academics as a
recipe so I was just a nerd went to the
best college I could and at 20 I studied
abroad in Germany for a year and read
Rich Dad Poor Dad and those two things
just blew up my world because I was like
oh it even know you could start
businesses and some didn't even occur to
me and then traveling the world and all
that so in my 20s I couldn't
you're out business because the internet
was it like it is now and I tried a
bunch of stuff funny failure stories
that went nowhere and I ended up going
back to what I know which is education
so I was a teacher so I taught high
school in psychology for about five
years and then in fact in psychology
yeah yes my undergrad I started English
major and switched to psychology in
undergrad yeah and then at age 30 says
nine years ago I was like okay that's it
I love teaching I was super happy even
though I wasn't making a ton cuz I was
chopping the world and I'm smart with
money just like you said earlier well I
I just had this burning desire like I
have to figure out this entrepreneur
thing so it's been a long journey these
nine years I had a lot of things to
learn and a lot of things to unlearn I
used to edit out contractions from
people's emails on my team because I was
like that's not official and now I
would've made you wanted to be
conversational I can't even spell so I
get up early so so I really started kind
of hitting my stride figuring my srin
ish in 2016
surd a podcast called copy that pops so
it's like writing that stands out for
business yeah psychology tips and and
then at the end of the year I had three
people I really respect tell me why
don't you write a book like we've seen
you have a writing as your superpower
for nonfiction so why don't you have a
book and I was like oh I thought I had
to wait for permission and decided to
like [ __ ] that let's just go so I wrote
self-published a book it's over 360
pages in 30 days and figured out how to
hit number one bestseller in categories
in Amazon and after that people started
asking me for help to do the same thing
it's writing and self-publishing and
doing fun launches and then using their
books to get more speaking gigs and more
podcast interviews and all this stuff so
that's what I've been doing so
specifically nonfiction helping
entrepreneurs to write self-published
books but now that I've got this guy I'm
even more passionate about what goes in
kids heads and kids worlds make sense
specifically clothing because when I was
um doing like baby shower planning I
would not reveal the gender because I
didn't want an explosion of pink or blue
and it seems like with kids clothes like
that's all there is this like super
gender stereotypes which drives me
absolutely insane
and I want there to be more like
business-related fun stuff to kind of
like what you what you did so I'm really
passionate about that and then also kids
books I think there may be more
diversity inclusiveness right now here's
the best part of the Internet and and
just the world we live in you everything
you're passionate about you can execute
no totally I'm 100% going to you my
Christian work for you is like how could
I
uniquely structure that maybe as a
combination of maybe like kids clothes
kids books that are business-related and
diverse and and maybe an access model
I'm kind of try saying so you're more I
think what I'm hearing is more just a
question of like what from the beginning
of it will give it a more likelihood of
success yeah and it's like so where I've
made most of my money in the past few
years is high-end private clients good I
don't want to do that anymore just
because he takes up you time so I I'm
kind of trying to explore more products
and group access I got it I got it yeah
I think look here's the good news I
think you're on it I think I think the
reason I keep bringing up group access
is because I think it's a big business
idea I think if you start a
infrastructure around clothes and books
and access to you for you know three
hours a week you know Monday 8:00 to
9:00 you're gonna obviously his schedule
is gonna change as he goes through so
you have to figure out what works for
you and it might be just one hour
you know 9:00 to 10:00 on Friday p.m.
you know one hour but yes I think
starting a business that says this is my
business it is going to be diverse and
inclusive whether it's kids with
disability whether it's black brown you
know that's amazing and obviously very
much on a consciousness of at least half
the country and and many more than that
for that matter and so you know I think
there's a lot of a business opportunity
there and I think access is gonna be the
biggest you know lever I do believe that
access is the emerging leverage point
and so I think it's a book and close
Club with the person that is the person
you know like imagine the first time
Harry Potter came out if she
available obviously she's in the news a
lot now for a lot of different things
but like you know like people want
access period end of story if my next
book that I write
comes with if you buy this book there's
a unique barcode on the back of every
book and you get to be part of a closed
okay see he like see baby II likes this
idea you know and so I yes I I actually
think you haven't figured it out I think
see reverse engineer how much time
you're willing to give and then you'll
be able to amortize you're not gonna be
able to have high-end clients paying you
a thousand you're gonna have a lot more
people paying you 50 but the good news
is its scalable the high-end clients
whether you're charging them a thousand
or five hundred thousand you can only
have so many you're just one woman a
super woman but like one woman I think
that if you go to the $50 access instead
of the thousand dollar I don't know your
numbers and it might be ten dollars it
might be five but I think you'll get to
that income level and it's gonna cost
you an hour right instead of costing you
all that other time and I think you set
it up that way from day one it's almost
like Costco from day one you can buy my
book
you can buy my shirt but but but there's
this really epic thing that gives you
this access and I think you'll see
eighty percent fifty percent thirty
percent sign up for that and that will
be the trigger and what do you think on
pricing like with its Fitz parsers like
send me to you then you're like no
ninety nine for a 12-pack plus access
for every idea that I do I do I think
that I think that there you know a
couple things if you go the route of
selling the book or close without the
access you may have a lot of people that
then say you're not worth the extra
hundred bucks so you've got to first
make a decision of do I build a model
where you know you only I love this
you've got Gary B baby II and a [ __ ]
be I mean this is just like perfect I
love it like you love it
so I really I really think that you need
to decide if you're gonna sell the books
for clothes outside of access I would
actually recommend not because men
you can bundle the fee so now all of a
sudden the books are $55 when everybody
knows the book is really 15 that you
know but what comes along with that book
is you're part of this group and we're
here every single week 52 weeks a year
for these two hours live here's the
passcode and you know and I think you
should sell it yourself this way you
have the email so that you can give them
access right you don't have to worry
about the code that I just talked about
that's why I would structure as first
pricing I think people would absolutely
I think a hundred dollars a month is an
incredible price point so if they did a
book at a piece of clothing that
normally would have been 40 bucks and
that you that now are making that extra
sixty and you can make that you know
think about that you get if that's $60
and you get a thousand people if you
grind hard for a couple years now you've
got $60,000 in monthly recurring revenue
that you're probably making what you're
probably making you know twenty thousand
in profit because you got to make the
book and the you know what have you and
I think you've got something and then
you can tear it right because somebody
could buy a month for a hundred forty
somebody could buy six months for a buck
ten or a year for up but 99 you're
all-in for 50 on your hard goods on the
book and the clothes per month maybe
they get a book and a piece of clothing
but what the real game is is it's this
access thing and then you're putting out
content constantly because then people
are buying into your access I mean the I
mean it's this is never gonna be the
route I'm gonna go because I'm making my
economics differently but I don't
begrudge it when somebody's bringing
value with access and I have a funny
feeling if I ask people how much they
would pay for a month for a bottle of
wine with me and having that small
access it would be high leave in the
comments if what your number would be
and don't make it up it's just good data
for everybody who's watching right now
for them to think about how they can do
it so don't say a thousand or whatever
to put what you would actually put so
that's how I feel or and would you take
like those hour sessions and chop them
up and do like your 64 or your two
hundred one of her pieces of content
from those yes I would yes I would
because the it's the same thing I do you
with you know the four DS it's a $12,000
beam or maybe a product but I put it out
right so like yes I would
40s or my favor
stuff they work so you can just like
you're a fly on the wall listening to
you yeah you're learning and and the
same thing there I have time here I have
time and I think that's why it's working
go awesome
bye little pilot bye baby requests what
if we get out to New York could we come
by for the day doesn't everything Cherie
write a book about it yes thank you
talked to Dustin or Zane or whoever set
you up here okay well thank you thank
you that was fun let's keep it movin
London Martinez 1200 I have to do that
it's 14,000 here thank you what's your
name John a I'm so well mixed somebody's
to see you donate thank you so much
you've been like amazing I love the way
you are with people and how much you
give and how much you offer and it's
just what do you live I live in
Charlotte but I'm a New Yorker
originally so I've been here for quite a
long time so I wanted to get on here and
talk to you because well a couple of
things so I'm one of those people that I
was listening I listened to you every
single day throughout the whole lockdown
every single day and I discovered you
probably this year I think and so just
to give a little back story when I first
moved here
you know when living in New York it was
all about the more you know the more
diversified you are the better candidate
you are for a job or anything you want
to do moving to the south
I felt like I started to get put into a
box that I had to focus on one thing the
problem is is I am still multifaceted
that I turn into sometime like this
crazy professor obsessed that I will get
a thousand different ideas at one time
that's good so when I hear I start I had
a graphic design visit a single parent
and I had a child that was really sick
and so I started teaching yoga I did
everything I could
I started a graphic design business I
had I was a mindfulness coach back then
when there was no such thing as
mindfulness now it's like a big deal I
owned an herbal body care company where
I created all the products myself from
scratch I formulated everything and at
that time nobody really knew what he ma
products were a robotic care products
were so like not like now everybody's
doing it so I spent a lot of time
educating people and at the end of the
day my products did pretty well but I
got really burnt yeah and creating
education I was doing training programs
I mean I just I just got burnt out and I
ran out of money
and I had to go back to work to relieve
my mind as well
and by the way donate that that's good I
just I really hope you understand and I
hope everybody on earth understands
that's not an L that's part of the
process yeah it's very important that
you do not look at that as a loss I mean
that in the micro it was a loss in the
macro it was a win because now at this
still young of an age and you know I
believe this [ __ ] you and I are younger
than we think first of all you look
[ __ ] fantastic for taking two number
two number two you just do I'm just
gonna play this out for a listen and I
every time I say this I always see so
many comments or no email me what if she
gets cancer yes I understand things
happen I also understand it's extremely
likely that we're talking about 38 42
years with the way medicine is
progressing you know that's a long
[ __ ] time donate like 38 years ago
you were 14 Ilana this happened since
you were 14 yeah so when you start
looking it at that way
so anyway nonetheless I just really want
to make sure that that experience that
you went through it's a building block
yes it was a loss but you didn't lose
and people need to understand that but
keep going so
you know going back to work has been
hard for me because I tend to get put in
a box all the time even when I work for
other companies they see me as a fixin
I'm really good at fixing things and
clearing out operations and you know I'm
in retail and so I'm always going and I
fix the stories and I make them
profitable I mean come on and I'm really
usually ready to get out but then I end
up stuck there so anyway during this
lockdown time I listened to you I
started a YouTube channel I on tik-tok
Instagram LinkedIn everywhere and I have
to tell you that even back then I
started a YouTube channel back then when
YouTube was not a big thing I started I
had blogs still sitting out there but
somewhere along the line something that
happened so I get all this inspiration
with a thousand ideas you know I love
beauty and then I love mindfulness and
then I really believe that one of my
purposes is to help the world see things
from different perspectives so George
Floyd happened I started doing videos on
George Floyd and how we can start
talking about race and how we can heal
is world I've done videos a video beauty
and I get all these different ideas and
they feel like they're in so many
different paths but I can't vary how to
all bring it all together
you don't think them all together to do
what well you do like they are I keep
watching I watched a lot of videos and
what to do if they say you know you
should have one thing that you're
talking about know donate donate they're
telling you how to win on YouTube I'm
trying to have you win in life okay like
like stick with me here like when when
you go through this process the you when
you say how to bring them all together
you don't bring them all together nor
though all together right you're the
part that brings it all together right
like you the human you the unique human
is how it all comes together the bigger
question is sports cards out here I'm
our company's reaching out to me saying
are you okay literally I had venture
capitalists reaching out to me saying
are you okay when they saw me make
videos of going garage saleing they're
like are you okay I'm like the [ __ ]
top course I'm okay then like like like
I'm talking about the Jets I'm talking
about social media I'm talking about
sports cards I'm talking about wrestling
I'm talking about business
entrepreneurship corporate life I'm from
a parenting I'm talking about tick-tock
you're what brings it together the
bigger question is when you are you
worried that by doing so many different
things that make you happy because
you're wildly creative cuz that's what
it is yeah now you're concerned that by
not having some look that doesn't allow
you to maximize dollars that allows you
to have stability to be at peace to be
able to do it okay listen there's
there's there's definitely some baggage
that comes along with being pretty I get
it listen listen donate listen I'm the
same as you what I have that is made at
work is the ability to make one thing
80% but go at it 110%
which gives me 20% to play vaynermedia
is my 80% right Gary beat gary vee
sports cards garage saleing social media
that's that's the 20% i go hard at both
but i think what you need is to find
your 80% thing and and in a world where
there's a lot of things you can do it's
literally literally rolling the dice or
throwing a dart or flipping a coin you
have so many patents I think that you
need to really think about having one
core main thing the steak and then side
dish everything else but don't eliminate
the side dishes because
there are the things that allow you to
focus on the main thing my baseball card
sports card thing my my get garyvee all
of that are the things that allow me to
actually be a very good CEO for
vaynermedia because if I didn't have
this side stuff I wouldn't be able to be
happy because I would burn out from
vaynermedia because my brain would want
to do other things I allow myself to do
other things at what is perceived as the
shortcoming of the 80% but those other
things allow me to be 110% on the 80
does that make sense right so I think
you need to pick the sustainable thing
the thing they need a business
sustainable got it yeah me so you don't
have to do that you need to be able to
get out and do your you know your thing
at all times you need to pick one thing
that pays your bills enough to lie see
that's that's what I want for you
because once you are selling candles
direct-to-consumer or start any you know
an access business like I'm talking
about once you do that you're gonna be
then able to be a little bit more
creative and play with social media and
do other side things and talk about
meditation or racial injustice but you
need the thing that is your oxygen your
well your you know that allows
everything else to happen but you're
gonna need those other things to happen
and people that tell you to focus on one
thing are wrong because you're wired to
need the other stuff like me but but the
part that you're missing right now
good news we got fifty two more years to
drill this is I need you to build
something that is sustainable as your
one thing but not cut off everything
because then that's holding your breath
and you're gonna eventually breathe and
the whole thing's gonna break so you
need to build a sustainable thing but
still do up 20% of the side stuff but
you've got to figure out what that
sustainable thing is because I was
thinking I can maybe go back to making
some products again many things that I
did before if I started with one or two
things and then building it from there
what if what is historically giving you
the most success sorry out of all the
things you've ever done what was the
thing that maybe
work the best I'm so low level anything
on the solo that's uh so not love no
like actual business success what's the
most successful thing you've done by
you're like as an entrepreneur versus as
an executive the most and what burns you
out from what what and what ended up
happening really there I just is that
first of all whole manufacturing and I
couldn't grow it enough I didn't have
the money so it was really trying to you
need money in order to grow because you
can only manufacture so much from your
home you know I mean but you could also
start a business that does pre-selling
yeah you know you could sell futures a
lot of people that don't have dollars
don't realize the thing they have is
their passion and their clout and a
business model that takes the money
before it comes in if you come out if
you came out and said this soap is gonna
be $25 but if you order it now which
comes in several months it'll be fifteen
all of a sudden you can take those
dollars and you can manufacture more you
know that way I think so and you're
gonna be at the mercy of how much people
trust you and I'm not everyone's gonna
trust you but enough people are gonna
trust you to allow you to do that
great pre something that's a good idea
thank you I have more question I have a
I have a client meeting in one minute
okay you mean the thing that I do yeah
yeah thank you so much I think he
crashed again but yeah no problem - all
right
okay well Garry's computer crashed again
so I guess I'll just end this show for
me thank you everyone for watching I'll
read some of the comments thank you to
people with a passion it's going too
fast
deejay kingpin anyway Gary's gotta go to
a meeting so I don't think he's gonna
make it back and thanks everyone for
watching please come back
tomorrow we're gonna have the sports
card episodes tomorrow what else watch
this
oh go follow Gary VTV on Twitter and I'm
gonna play this promo so you kind of
figure out what that is and yeah see you
tomorrow bye bye
the people that are gonna win over the
next five to seven years are gonna be
very comfortable in control of the
process this is requires sacrifice all
your actions have to get mapped back
back back back back class nobody gives a
[ __ ] about where you grew up the whole
game is scaling the unscalable it's
[ __ ] hard work it's being respectful
it's being a good person to that that's
just a good idea it's there the flip
game is there this house right here
there's $400 to do it I stay my lady
like real [ __ ] tight but you can't be
crippled everybody here is judging
themselves you're looking at what's in
front of you right now
you're losing because you're laying in
your bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling you're upside let me
just say it one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground up who the
[ __ ] you are whoever provides the most
value always you're entering
the greatest five year window of your
life my only answer today Ernie but like
it's just like try [ __ ] don't your
business down and go work for an apparel
company potaters nobody you've ever met
got there without the hard work so you
better get your speed up
you better work harder you better work
smarter if you can't Google stuff you're
not gonna be able to do anything that
I'm kind of Gary PPT be like hell to
check me out hope you enjoy it